i know you're a simpsons fan and my my
old my old friends at the simpsons
they're doing a show at uh the hollywood
bowl
i tweeted about this yes and you
apparently tweeted about it because
you're excited about it
and uh they've asked me to come and sing
a song from one of my episodes the
monorail song and i said yes so i'm
going to do that in a couple of weeks
you're going to be amazing by the way
that's one of the best songs written for
that show
well thank you so much but here's my
question yeah i would i would love any
tips i've never
uh i never sang at the hollywood bowl i
and and you're here right now
and it's in a couple of weeks do you
think you could teach me anything well
uh uh sure analyze what i think i'm
going to analyze what you've got i kind
of need to hear
like a little bit of what i'm working
with right can is there anything serious
i know that you think
i mean i don't know
what do we figure is there a song i can
say again we've made it very clear i
have to sing something we don't have to
pay for
was there a song oh yeah how about an
irish lullaby to release sure that works
yes okay here we go check these out
as a young boy in killarney
so many years ago
me mum would sing a lullaby
in toons
would you
i'm all right i'm okay
yeah it's all right
[ __ ] would you like a sip of water no
no i'm fine
that was uh well that was glorious um
that was absolutely amazing
my my my only comment would be you know
you have a very high very it's your i
feel your
like you're singing from your heart and
from your your throat and i feel like
you need to sing from your
balls conan i feel like you need to
bring it down
down to the depths of your soul i tried
that once there was
there was swelling and discomfort for a
long time
for from the balls okay so i gotta get
it you're saying is get
[Applause]
you can do this yes so as a singer
you're like i'm here and you're like
there
is what you're saying we are so close
so close not even noticeable to the
untrained ear you're such a good sport
yes
to put up with me uh i uh well i hope
you come by when i do it i will be there
for sure
wow that'd be fantastic but trying to
run my hand up your pant leg no doubt
only i will not try to stop you yeah
he'll wear the loosest pants he has
i'm going to wear it hammer mc hammer
genie pants
get up there grover there's plenty of
room you cruel temptress
higher grovin higher